make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin you know i gotta be honest
with you guys i'm a little sad that al
ewing's run on the incredible hulk is
going to be ending relatively soon uh
because
it's alewings right on the hulk it's one
of these weird things right like if
you're not a fan of alguin's writing
style you're gonna hate the hulk but if
you love al ewing's writing style you're
gonna love the hulk it's one of these
things where there really isn't an
in-between here it's
it's kind of divisive right it doesn't
mean people hate it this only just means
it's not necessarily for them right so
what we're doing here is we're covering
this kind of one shot called time of
monsters right which is kind of
one of these stories where it looks like
it's introducing a new version of the
hulk that seems to be the case and it's
really cool
right so what this does is this whole
story takes place about 9 500 years
before the modern day and what it looks
like is it's the very first
host of the one below all right the very
first person to ever really be exposed
to his power
and to really take it on in his full
totality now what you end up doing here
is picking up with a kid by the name of
tammuz
and basically the leader of a local
village and the way this is kind of told
is that at some point in their early
days like a lot of primitive cultures
they worshipped essentially a goddess
right and this idea was that the land
they lived
in was lush and green and it was
beautiful and there were all kinds of
animals and plants and things for them
to feed and feast and so on and so forth
but ultimately all they did was consume
and they never gave anything back and so
as time passed the land began to become
barren
it began to lose its rich water deposits
uh the various
animals that existed there were either
completely consumed or fled
and this was interpreted by the tribe as
being punishment by the goddess for the
fact that they just never gave to her
the way they were supposed to that all
they did was took and they never gave
back
and so the result of this is you have
what's kind of called the green light
right and it's almost like this pit that
exists down there
and what happens is seemingly people are
sacrificed to it now tamu seems like one
of these kids
or really the part of the generation and
that usually happens with each passing
generation
they fall less and less in line with the
particular religious beliefs of the
generation before them
and so this is no different and what you
end up having here is tamuza kind of
comes forward or not really comes
forward but word has reached the ears of
the village elder that he's not he
doesn't really hold the faith
the way other people do right his faith
is as described as having faltered right
that he believes that the the village
elder is essentially rattled that he's
losing his mind
that things need to change and things
need to progress but he's holding on to
the way things used to be and so the
result of this is that tammuz has
basically been chosen as a sacrifice now
there's going to be a lot of duplicity
that goes on here that'll actually be
established
later on but ultimately tomus is kicked
inside this pit and when he is he
sacrificed to this kind of green eye
which literally starts tearing his body
apart right it's almost like a like it
just kind of absorbs him in the sense
that it's almost like a gravity well
right it just kind of starts sucking him
in
and ripping the flesh from his bones in
a pretty gruesome way and then he's
completely consumed by it like kind of
consumed by this this
green eye as they call it and when that
happens the green door opens
now for those of you guys who are just
joining us with regards to the
incredible hulk stuff one
i highly suggest you check out the
playlist down in the description to get
caught up on everything
related to the immortal hulk but two as
a kind of quick run over here the green
door is essentially an access point
right and it's almost like a door of the
chosen so when a particular individual
out there dies and they've been exposed
to gamma radiation which is essentially
the case here right if anything it's
probably more like a gamma
uh meteorite right or some kind of
artifact that's been exposed to gamma
radiation somewhere along the line
that uh that when a person's been
exposed to gamma and they basically die
the green door opens which takes them to
the realm of the one below all
if they choose to pass through it and
when that happens tammuz is essentially
taken to the realm of the one below all
now what we end up getting here is this
kind of of
explanation right something that goes on
with regards to his friend now his
friend is a kid by the name of shaleem
who's
actually the son of the village elder
himself and the way this played out is
that at some point in the past uh
tammuz's mother actually died and he was
more or less adopted
by the village elder who kind of took
him on as something akin to a son
it's not necessarily one of these exact
things where he is a biological son it's
more just kind of an adoption process
but the important thing is that shalem
has kind of a
an uneasy feeling about what's going on
with tammuz and he's kind of out and
about uh seemingly doesn't really know
where he is
and the concern is almost kind of this
ache in his stomach that something's
going something's happened to him now
when his father returns home of course
he asked him like do you know where
where tammuz is and his answer is
no like why do you ask and that's when
chilean picks up on the fact that he's
done something to him now when he goes
to attack his dad
his dad immediately you know just kind
of knocks him down refers to him as a
milk stop basically a colloquial term
for somebody who's weak or incapable
of of handling themselves in any real
measurable way that has to like rely on
others for help and things like that and
so the result of this is that one of the
hunters comes running back
and talks of a beast that has appeared
in the woods in an area near the uh
tribe and that it'll basically be enough
because of its size it'll be enough to
feed them for quite some time and so
what you end up doing is switching over
to uh tammuz who's basically re-emerged
as a hulk-like monster and it's one of
these funny things because even though
he's here
traditionally as what we would call a
hulk he's not here with nefarious
purposes
instead in being here he's realized
certain things that one there's actually
water below ground and if the water can
be irrigated then it'll be enough for
the tribe to be able to sustain
themselves to grow crops different
things like that
presumably animals will return to this
place and it's a way to kind of turn it
back into a lush
environment and that's what he starts
doing right he literally starts tearing
through the ground
trying to get to this water and so
because of that he looks pretty he looks
pretty badass i mean to the average
person who sees him he looks wildly
monstrous and almost like a demon
entity and that's how the village
village members treat him that when he
emerges he's trying to talk to them
trying to have a conversation with him
but all that comes out are just garbled
growls
and in his frustration he lashes out
much like we've seen with the incredible
hulk do
with regards to people who are kind of
moving against him and so the result of
this is that he's essentially
killed by an arrow uh which is fired by
shaleem
not knowing that it's to moose but
ultimately he ends up coming across the
corpse and then he sees a tattoo
or a birthmark on his body and realizes
that it's that it's
that he's somehow been changed or
modified or altered and so the result of
this is that when he kind of dies
and he falls back to the realm of the
one below all that essentially he's kind
of met by the one below all himself and
when this happens the one below all kind
of tells him like you bear my mark right
like
i turn my face towards you i am the one
below all and he says with these hands i
break with this mouth i howl
my weapon is hate and the reality is to
moose felt betrayed by his own tribe and
so when that happens
uh he basically says like so is mine
right he's basically bound by vengeance
here and so that's what's kind of crazy
is because following that
they actually end up feasting on the
body of of tammuz in his hulk form you
know and just kind of like
like literally eating all parts of him
and that's when the village elder kind
of stands up and says like this beast
was brought here as a bounty to us right
it was
brought to us here by the goddess right
she gave it to us uh and and that we
destroyed it and we we killed it so it
means that she still cares about us it's
a gift she's simply just testing us
right she's putting us through these
paces with this harsh environment
because she wants us wants to make sure
that we're worthy whatever excuse he
chooses to use
to one essentially maintain his own
position and two to keep things
as they are the other thing that happens
is that as they continue to go through
and to consume this corpse that shaleem
does not but he also begins to notice
that one of the eyes is starting to open
up right that it's just
slightly open and that's what he tells
his father like no like do not eat this
thing but they consume it anyway right
they're consuming the gift of the
goddess that's been given to them and
the hope that by consuming the gift that
she's given they're essentially
offering right they're giving something
back they're showing appreciation
and then in turn their their realm will
start to kind of grow back to the way
that it was before
that you know life will return so on and
so forth and they can go back to
no longer living such a harsh and
terrible life the exact
opposite happens that as they consume
this corpse it literally starts to
destroy them right it starts to kill
them
and break them all down until
essentially the eye completely opens and
tamu starts to reform right because now
he's essentially
an immortal hulk given that gift by the
one below all like he literally starts
to grow starts to reform and then turns
his vengeance to shalem now for his part
shaleem really didn't know that it was
tamus like he really had no idea that it
was his best friend
that he had essentially killed right
even his brother if we're being honest
with ourselves he didn't realize that
that he had fired the arrow in his own
friend's eye and essentially brought him
to an end but ultimately
uh the response of two moves is i don't
care right like you know in
one of these instances he kind of has
essentially the voice of the one below
all kind of speaking into his mind
saying like you will never be a rid of
your vengeance right you'll never be rid
of your anger and your wrath that will
always be a part of you right that's
gonna be who you are
forevermore and so the results of this
is that he basically kills shaleem now
the reason why this matters this is one
of the reasons why this story is so cool
is because following that he just goes
forward out into the world he doesn't
die
right he's not killed by by shaleem it's
not like chilemio has to kill his own
friend again
and then kind of go forward from there
like it literally says tammuz leaves the
village alone right like he he's the
only person that emerges from this place
presumably he's gonna show up and
probably face off against the immortal
hulk which would be cool
i don't really know what what name to
give this guy maybe like the demon hulk
or something like that which is kind of
a cool name because he he looks like a
demonic character right he looks like a
demonic being and unlike the immortal
hulk which is just kind of a
manifestation from bruce banner and is
still in a lot of ways a relative good
guy depending on the circumstance but
doesn't really intend to cause
harm to other people tamu seems to be
the exact same way right like the hate
hulk that's basically what he is like
he's literally bound by hate
and vengeance and that's it right he's
just going forward it's kind of like
this force
of of violence this force of seemingly
entropy so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you